All right, let's go back to the phones at
(617) 830-4750.
We will talk to our caller from the two one
five area code two one five.
Oh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
[inaudible] hi David, this is Dre from Philadelphia.
How are you?
I'm good.
Good.
So my question isn't about impeachment, but
it's a little bit more about education.
All right.
So a few weeks ago, I think you had a caller
call in about, you know, how he thinks pre-recs
and humanitarian classes maybe should be eliminated.
And I agree that I think we do need them as
a society to better understand each other
and be more empathetic as the previous color
had alluded.
My question is, what are your thoughts on
the fact that everything is becoming like
doctorial prepared?
So I think that that's like contributing to
B, um, loan crisis.
So like a physical therapist and occupational
therapist has to now go back and be a doctorate.
Like, do you think that that is something
that we should be striving towards?
I don't know.
I'm not aware of that.
So hold on.
Let me see if I, you're saying that occupational
therapists have to be, uh, doctors.
Now I've just, I'm just not familiar enough
with what you're saying.
Yes.
So in the medical field.
So I'm a nurse and going back, I'm getting,
I'm currently in my final year, I'm going
to be a nurse practitioner next year and I'm
getting my masters.
But the big push is, is that they want me
to get my DNP instead of my MSN.
So it would be that I would be a doctorate
of nursing practice versus just having my
masters, which, um, my scope of practice does
not change regardless of me having either
credential.
It's the same for occupational therapy, physical
therapist, speech therapist, they all now
have to get doctorate of practice in their
respective fields.
So let me ask you this, let me ask you this.
I hate to be the cynical, but does that allow
a higher reimbursement rate from insurance?
Like as much more my mind mind goes is, is
this about money more than anything else?
That is a great question.
And I do not know the question in terms of
reimbursement from a nursing standpoint.
Some it's state driven.
So like in Pennsylvania, I can practice independently,
but I still need a doctor to oversee, um,
you know, my practice.
Yeah.
But I don't necessarily, but nurse practitioners
as a whole are reimbursed at say 87%.
I don't know the exact numbers.
87% versus the doctor, 95% sure based on insurance
companies.
And I'm almost certain that it doesn't matter
if you have your DMP versus your MSN.
Okay.
Cause I mean, listen, I don't know enough
about it to say too much more, but when I
hear about a push for a more involved degree
in order to see patients where my mind goes
is that probably is more profitable for the
place that you're working at.
Gotcha.
Yes, that is true.
And do you think that it's also related to
colleges wanting to make more money by forcing
us to always get more and more degrees?
Uh, yeah.
I mean listen, the incentive is certainly
there.
I just, I don't want to con it sounds reasonable.
I just don't want to say for sure cause I'm
just not familiar enough with the specifics
of what you're asking about.
But it certainly would not surprise me that
that's the case.
Okay.
Perfect.
Um, thank you so much for your time.
All right.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.